some of your personal hairs now this is
rapid fire so uh
carl personal heroes barack obama
james baldwin um
man it's difficult because i feel like
um you'll have to only have to name one
my father
um my mother
and my late wife that's beautiful
and i know carl and you know we all said
it i mean it's
you know in this show it helps so many
people because so many people write in
to me and talk we talk about loss we
talk about
you know uh adversity and anxiety and
depression and everybody deals with it
and you know i think the show tries to
normalize that
and you know my heart always it just it
just sank when i heard about your and
it's been i think 10 years now
and how do you how just briefly i know
you don't get personal and we can cut it
if you want but
how do you how do you move on what do
you do to
um continue on because i'm sure it felt
like this
bottomless pit this place where you're
like i don't you know and what
what helps what do you do well you go to
the bottom
because that's real or i mean i went to
my bottom
and then um in the bottom
i remembered that
connection the reason i say she was my
hero was because she lived with
a lot of illness for a long time in her
life but there was no way you would know
it
um and so that became a beacon
to get me back
um and there and what
one of the things that happens is that
initially
all you can think of is that loss it
takes up all of the space
in your being and you forget that
you only feel the size of the loss
because the magnitude of the joy was
that much greater
and as that begins to flood back in
um literally uh the loss is carried
downstream
and you're left with this beautiful
river of memory
of water what you still have with
you carl i'm gonna yeah i'm just
on the verge of tears right now and i'm
honestly calling you
every time i experience loss i'm calling
carl lumley
you're going to help me through life see
some of your posts michael about
your grandmother or your aunt and you
know it just
it's um they're so dear it's such a
different side of you which i
i don't know and so reading your posts
it's like i've gotten to know you a
little bit better through them
and they're so heartfelt and vulnerable
vulnerable i mean
so they just broke my heart but in a
a wonderful way thank you you know i i
think that what i've learned is
you know you try to while they're here
you know
tell them how much you love them and
obviously it's never enough you're like
i could have done this i could have said
that that's just something that i think
everyone does but you know i start
thinking about you know my uncle
who's an amazing man and i'm like you
know i'm thinking about him why don't i
just
post how i feel about my uncle how great
he is and i do it and i post about
someone i love or i admire or uh i try
to do things
now before that just so they know how
much i love them
just because i know how how emotional i
am and how devastated i'll be so i'm
trying to protect myself
but also you know uh speak the truth
especially my friend grant imahara who
you know was such an amazing man
49 years old brain aneurysm gone he was
a
usc grad he made robots he
was on mythbusters he but he was the
most down-to-earth
fun-loving gentle soul and it just
stays with me because it's you know you
it's he's my age he's our age he's
it's just like this young man who had so
much that just for some reason i mean
obviously
obvious reasons anyway george um and i
know
you know you lost your mother when you
were 15. and i know she was a big
supporter of yours and
again to you it's like you know what
what was i mean you were young
you were a kid you know and she was it
was good you know i
i don't know but i think her mother my
grandmother was a
big big influence in my life so um she
was the first
lawyer in arkansas and uh just a
matriarch she was like auntie mame and
she was sort of sort of the
hero in my life and and and also one of
the other heroes is uh
this is going to sound strange uh i uh
i was raised in the south i was raised
in arkansas and there was a
african-american man black man who lived
with us who was basically
my mother my mother was a terrible
alcoholic and all the rest of it so he
lived with
us he raised my mother's family and he
was with us and i considered him
practically my father my father was very
always at work and
sort of distanced so levi was his name
and he was my hero and i still think
about him to this day
greatest greatest man that's amazing so
yeah so he was my mother and father
figure in many respects
yeah you know what it sounds so cliche
but don't you really believe that you
know i
i try to practice what i preach
and i'm not a doctor but like you know
on this show it's like you know when you
do have loss
you know some you know people go really
low and they start to drink or they
start to do drugs and they start to and
they just can't deal with it
and it really i know it sounds kind of
surfaced
but if you think about like is this what
they'd want you to do
like is this how you're like you know uh
you're dealing with it there you know
this happens so don't you want to live
the best life you can maybe for them or
maybe
i mean i think there's some truth to
that it's like i want to make my
grandmother's
grandfather smile up in the heavens i
want to say hey i'm doing this all for
you you are here you're the reason i'm
here you're the reason i'm doing it
and without you i wouldn't have been
able to do it and so i i believe that
yeah in so many ways yeah and also you
know i i
i believe that more we co-create with
god and my
relationship with god for me is very
important and i i feel like the more
i can get in tune with what
what the bigger picture is the happier i
am you know what i mean
that's always i i'm always better when
i'm i'm i just let go of this and
yeah go with i say whatever
makes you happy whatever works for you
you do and everyone should respect that
and love that whether
you know whether it's spiritual whether
it's god whether whatever it is that's
why i mean we wouldn't have [ __ ] wars
if people could just say hey i love that
love that don't just don't tell me what
to do
i believe what you want to believe what
i get it i get it all right i know but
by the way but i believe in god it's so
astonishing about this conversation
is like everyone has their sorrow and
everyone has their story
and you never know when you walk into
these rooms what somebody's story is
you know we we think everybody else has
their [ __ ] together and we think
everybody else has so much
confidence and look at them and aren't
they fabulous they're
fabulous and talented and they've got it
all together
meanwhile he just lost his wife she just
lost her mother
um she's been battling depression you
know we don't know
exactly what people are carrying around
and everyone's carrying around
something so susan who's your hero you
know i don't
it's nothing like it's not like oh it's
you know michelle obama it's
nothing's jumping out except there are
some people that i've met through
twitter
that are fighting the good fight you
know it's one thing to like puff
puff you know tweet something as wonder
woman and come off as brave and get like
you know
100 people to think it's fabulous but
there are people like shannon watts who
you know started this um campaign
against the nra
and to work for gun control and she gets
death threats and she
you know they're just so many people who
are on the front lines
of whatever their cause is and they're
unafraid and unapologetic
and they're speaking their truth to the
to
power and i have so much respect for
that
somebody like shannon somebody like
these you know the politicians or the
or people in the private sector who are
trying to get
[ __ ] done or trying to change our
climate
or you know make our lives better but
aren't just talking about it or tweeting
about it doing it out there
doing it and i have such respect for
that i love that
phil see i said don't you start singing
we don't need another hero
phil who's your hero
what if we did a musical with all our
voices like all our characters
and my mother beautiful both people who
overcame obstacles to
you know achieve great like my mother
was the first person in her family
also from arkansas george wow
seventh of eight kids first one to go to
college first one in the
entire family history to go to college
and not only that but then provided the
ability for me to go to college right
i love and city point just you know as
someone just who else
who worked on a personal level but on a
symbolic level as well
you know right think about the adversity
we can't even imagine
well right i can't even imagine i can't
you guys can imagine carl can imagine
phil can imagine more than i can imagine
not me i'm the white i really am
exactly right it's like but but that's
the thing to accomplish what he
accomplished
when he accomplished it yeah those
people on the front lines
for all those years talk about bravery
yeah uh maria maria
who's your hero oh yeah so when you said
personal hero that i think of people
that i
want to be like that i admire their
character and their actions and
the person i look up to as a person of
faith as a christian is jesus and that's
who i want to be like that's who i
call on to renew me change me
uh save me so i think of
him as number one and then people that i
know personally in the flesh uh i think
about
um people whose capacity to love to me
that's
always something i'm in awe that they
love
in spite of so many reasons not to love
i think that's really the goal
and i think about um my husband
because he i admire his capacity to love
his compassion his patience
and even though we argue and i don't
like some things i
i like so much about him and i want to
be
like him in so many ways um
that's awesome you know as i've matured
i'm able to actually
look at very flawed people that i have
focused on the negatives about
and actually admire them
like my mother who i was able to really
mourn
years after her death because i i
focused on
all the frustrations i had i focused
also on
why wasn't i even better for her
and my husband says you were you're i
can tell you as an outsider you were
you did a of the best you can and you
did a lot
but you know i think i should have done
more especially as a person of faith i
should have been able to
love even more i should have been able
to uh forgive immediately
sooner and and take even more crap
but um i realized that that i'm limited
i'm limited in my own flesh and i was
actually
the best i i could be at the time and it
was
pretty good coming from somebody else's
opinion that i
respect like my husband i love it i have
you know i feel like i think about
you know i definitely think of my
grandfather just
unconditional love i remember him
handwriting letters to me all the time
just saying mike i just i'm so
proud of you we've always been proud of
you before anything ever happened you
know that we love you
we only want to see you do well we we
you know it's just we love enjoy that
you enjoy us so much we're grandparents
most people don't really give a [ __ ]
about uh
you've always loved us and called us
every and so i always think of him
and my grandmother ruthie